welcome back to new rock stars it's me
mt and this is a season one breakdown of
the animation toward the force pun
intended that is star wars visions and
man oh man is this series one of the
most incredible and imaginative pieces
of star wars media that i have ever
witnessed with these haitian eyeballs
star wars visions is of course a nine
episode collection of nine separate star
wars stories told by different animation
studios who were given free reign to
give us some of the most visually
distinctive and memorable star wars
moments that frankly have never really
been seen before like i may have never
heard the wolf cry to a blue cord moon
but i have seen a trend ocean get
impaled by a freaking red lightsaber
umbrella so you know i imagine that's
just as cool but anyways i'm going to be
breaking down some of the cool little
easter eggs and details that you may
have missed in lucasfilm's newest star
wars anthology series heavily inspired
by anime and japanese culture so let's
get into it my four sensitive nerd
babies and i really love how they
started this series off with a heavily
akira kuwasawa inspired episode called
the duel because director george lucas
famously was inspired to create star
wars from kurosawa's samurai films like
the in fortress it's literally why darth
vader's suit is designed like a freaking
samurai specifically after the ancient
samurai warlord date masamune and also
of course what inspired that badass
ahsoka tana episode from mando season 2
that i think about every night that
sounds weird and the episode even starts
off very similarly to an old school
black and white kurosawa film with the
title of this black and white anime
being displayed in a very similar to his
titles and judging by the stormtrooper
armor of the bandits that come rolling
into town these bandits are remnants of
the sequel trilogy's first order after
bbh trusty assistant rey helped take
them all down and you can see helmets
from both the original trilogy and
sequel trilogy on all of these
men and the music that plays when they
approach their hostages starts off
similarly to john williams first order
theme but then deviate seemingly to
represent the deviation of these first
order troops from their original mission
but anyways when the village guards
mount a counter-attack we find a number
of classic star wars alien races among
them like a dog like subulba from the
phantom menace a trend ocean like the
bounty hunter boss a three-eyed gran a
tuscan raider recreating that iconic
shot from a new hope an ra7 model
protocol droid and even a viper model
imperial probe droid with a freaking
sword in each arm which is literally a
lot more than your regular probe joys in
my opinion like tarkin would have gotten
those rebel base coordinates out of leia
a lot faster if he used that probe droid
with the swords instead what are you
doing tarkin i thought you were smart
i'm gonna probe ya but the duel really
kicks it up a notch when the
show-stopping bandit leader voiced by
the amazing lucy lou shows up with her
impractically incredible umbrella ass
lightsaber to throw some shade on the
village guard
and though i am not a fashionista i am a
big fan of how she wears the bottom of
like a japanese oni mask to represent
that she is truly a demonic predator
properly prepared for parasol
penetration like literally say what you
will about dark side users but their
mother know how to terrorize in style
i don't know why all the art majors are
sith and scary poppins is absolutely
wrecking shop you know that is until
brian t's ronin shows up and when the
two finally face off you can notice the
poster art for the original star wars
movie on a nearby billboard which i
thought was a really funny nice touch
and in the episode poppins also notes
that it has been a long time since she
has had the pleasure of committing a
murder against a jedi which makes me
think that she could have been one of
darth vader's inquisitors in the past
but as their fight progresses i couldn't
help but notice the parallels between
their battle and obi-wan and anakin's
fight in revenge of the sith like it's
almost like a complete reversal because
while two blue lightsabers clash down a
river of red lava on a harsh planet
deadly to life two red lightsabers
clashed down a blue river of water on a
green planet so it's literally like the
opposite of that scenario and at the
battle's conclusion we find out that
this mysterious ronin has been on a
mission to hunt down dark side users and
collect their red kyber crystals general
grievous style in a way why probably
because they're all but hey
everyone needs a hobby and also in case
you're unaware kyber crystals are the
crystals that jedi and sith use to power
their lightsabers and what the empire
used as the main power source for
palpatine's galaxy gripping game sphere
it's spherical
hysterical and like the end of every
star wars visions episode this episode
ends with a card saying inspired by star
wars created by george lucas to imply
that while these star wars vision
stories are super badass and cool
they're merely visions of other star
wars universes so the events in these
stories aren't canon to the main star
wars continuity but anyways the tone of
star wars vision shifts drastically in
the more kid-friendly second episode
called tatum rhapsody which is of course
a reference to bohemian rhapsody the
famous very long song that that band
made
and it's an episode where a padawan on
the run from order 66 and his two to
four other band mates i don't know if
that other person counts as three other
friends or one friend three-headed man i
don't know perform for job of the hutt
on tatooine to try to convince him to
free their hut bandleader geezer yeah
this one isn't my favorite as i am about
two decades over the episode's target
audience but i did appreciate the nods
to star wars history that this episode
does include like how jabba repurposed
tatooine's pod racing garages and
stadium from the phantom menace and how
the cantina band from a new hope
silently feels uncomfortable around any
music that isn't space jazz which you
know understandable they know one song
also i was quite pleasantly surprised to
see temura morrison reprising his role
as boba fett considering the tone of
this episode but i honestly wouldn't
want it any other way just real quick
this video is brought to you by the
ridge the ridge wallet is like sleek and
industrial it's designed to fit in your
front pocket unlike those bulky back
pocket wallets that we won't talk about
here because this is a ridge wallet zone
it holds up to 12 cards and still has
room for cash the ridge wallet comes in
over 30 styles and colors including
carbon fiber and burnt titanium that's
how i like my titanium burnt there's
even an 18 karat gold plated wallet if
you're balling like that which i think
aisha and the other shiny sovereign
folks from guardians of the galaxy
volume 2 would appreciate because they
all about that gold life they may be
golden 24 7. and every ridge wallet
comes with a lifetime guarantee and
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days and send it back for a full refund
if you don't love it but it's highly
improbable because they make the best
wallets and it's got 30 000 5 star
reviews um they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets and optional device
charging batteries and they have a cool
event going on now where every dollar
spent on the website before september
18th enters you to win a 2020 jeep
gladiator or fifty thousand dollars if
you prefer cash and are really excited
to paint yourself gold to match your new
ridge wallet because that's what you do
but you know just don't affect yourself
with chemicals already
so get 10 off today with free worldwide
shipping and returns by going to
ridge.com new rockstars that's ridge
r-i-d-g-e dot com slash new rockstars
and use the code new rockstars and you
can find the link in the video
description below of course but luckily
the dopeness of star wars visions
reignites in its third episode titled
the twins where two twins born from the
dark side face off on what the episode
calls a gemini-class star destroyer with
death star-like planet destroying
capabilities much like palpatine's star
destroyers in the rise of skywalker and
gemini it most certainly is as it is
essentially two star destroyers duct
taped together undoubtedly to symbolize
the twins and their shattered
relationship by the end of the episode
and just the episode's overall theme of
duality like even the kyber crystal that
carre wields is red and blue to
represent his own struggle from darkness
to light and it's also super dope to see
more examples of being born purely from
the force outside of anakin skywalker
and i wonder if lucasfilm is trying to
get audiences reacquainted to the fact
that the force can even do something
like this because it's pretty damn
unbelievable but then again it's
probably the most believable
unbelievable thing that this episode
does because why are those children out
breathing in space and at the end of the
episode the droid is the one with the
air bubble and of course you gotta love
anytime anyone uses the force to stop a
laser blast like my boy kylo ren did in
the force awakens but i did notice that
the animators may have forgotten to
animate what happened to those frozen
stun rings as they completely disappear
when those troopers are force slammed
into the wall like we just don't see
them anymore but anyways the kyber
crystal suit designs for the twins khari
and am were of course model after darth
vader's with their droids being
elseworld's variants of r2d2 and c-3po
with duo in r duo meaning two like r2
and bton literally being one character
below the characters
c-3pno and there's also a couple of
classic star wars lines uttered in this
episode like when am asked kharay where
the hell he thinks he's going with the
family jewel and ricardo replies with to
a galaxy far far away and we also can't
forget the classic i've got a bad
feeling about this immediately followed
by kari saying it's not tractor beam
it's amp alluding to obi-wan's famous
that's no moon it's a space station you
know what while we're at it let's just
play every time star wars visions
mentions i've got a bad feeling about
this play the compilation john so you
have a bad feeling about this i have a
bad feeling about this you've got a bad
feeling about this i've got a bad
feeling about this and also since the
haldor maneuver from the last jedi is
easily in my top five favorite star wars
moments of all time you already know
your boy clapped like a seal with that
star destroyer got cut in half by khari
because god damn do i love when a star
destroyer gets cut in half in episode
four the village bride is a story set a
few years after the fall of the jedi the
episode's main character f voiced by
karen fukuhara from amazon's the boys
which is a show that you should 100 be
watching is a jedi padawan on the run
who ends up standing up for a village
being overrun by an army of old battle
droids from the clone wars repurposed by
a group of raiders on the planet
and you guys know what i always say if
you're gonna stand up for people in need
make sure you do it with a mother
freaking yellow katana lightsaber son
because that's what f did f does not
give an f she will kill you and along
with that katana lightsaber f also whips
around an arc 170 starfighter which was
a common republic ship during the clone
wars era while the raiders arrived in a
type of corellian yt series ship the
same type of ship as the millennium
falcon and finally at the end of the
episode f cuts her padawan braids
symbolically knighting herself as a jedi
since the jedi aren't around anymore she
had to do it herself because
the rules went out the window when windu
did and with episode 5 the ninth jedi my
personal favorite of the season we meet
kara in the very similar way to when we
beat rey for the first time in the force
awakens like even the music that plays
in the background is similar to rey's
theme that plays when she's scavenging
on the sandy jakku on her speeder
[Music]
and kara even uses a speeder just like
rey but a totally new and awesome thing
that this episode does with lightsabers
that is different from the current star
wars continuity is connect the kyber
crystal color in length to the heart and
force acuity of the wielder and since in
japanese the name kara means empty i
feel like she may have been named this
to symbolize the colorless nature of her
lightsaber at the beginning as well kara
and her father jima are voiced by two
marvel movie alums with kara being
voiced by kimiko glenn who played penny
parker in into the spider-verse and her
saber-smith father was voiced by none
other than shanghi himself simalu and in
episode 6 we are introduced to the
cutest and most wholesome character in
all of star wars history to be one my
son whose name is obviously inspired by
obi-wan and whose home is very much
modeled after luke's moisture farm on
tatooine and not only was his episode
obviously heavily inspired by japanese
anime classic astro boy but i also did
notice that there were some subtle
pinocchio imagery in this episode as
well in particular with mitaka's design
being extremely similar to that of
gepetto and this shot of tob1 staring
out into the night sky wishing that he
was a real jedi boy while a bright blue
star twinkled twankles in the background
possibly representing the blue fairy of
the force and also i just gotta say the
second i noticed mataka's head was
framed in a halo of toby's drawings i
knew that that big nose science daddy
was about to become one with the force
sometime within the next five minutes
speaking of toby's drawings i love them
they're so cute we have this picture of
the jedi temple on coruscant here and
when toby goes to find co3 at the very
beginning of the episode we can also see
a massive depiction of imperial walkers
and starfighters charging towards and
shooting at a luke skywalker in his
iconic pose from that original star wars
poster but we also get these two sets of
figures over here with one set depicting
what i'm assuming is obi-wan kenobi
versus general grievous from revenge of
the sith but up on the top there we see
a dark figure with two lightsabers
battling two white figures and i think
this dark figure could be a nod to asajj
ventress fighting obi-wan and anakin in
the clone wars series but it also could
be a nod to emperor darth sidious
himself as he has been known to have two
lightsabers on him despite mostly only
using one in the movies because you
gotta remember in revenge of the sith
that one of palpatine's lightsabers goes
straight out the window when he's
battling mace windu leaving him with
only one of his lightsabers left for his
battle with yoda and we have seen darth
sidious do wield before in a fight with
the super malio brothers in the clone
wars series and none of those malio
brothers were voiced by chris pratt what
the are you doing nintendo what
what and of course when toby's father is
killed in home destroyed by imperial
troops that of course mirrors what
happens to luke's family in a new hope
and when tob1 communicates with his
father's force ghost the atmosphere
resembles that of when calcastus
meditates in the fallen order video game
and i also thought it was a nice cute
touch to add the symbol of the jedi
order like comic book impact stars when
tlb1 hits that final blow against
general poopyhead who killed my dad
inquisitor man in episode 7 the elder we
have jedi padawan dan being avenged by
jedi knight tajin played by black
widow's david harbour after being
injured by an old dark side user called
the elder played by actor james hong and
i found it really cool how the elder's
face is literally designed to look like
a japanese oni demon mask with his
blades resembling demon horns as well as
his yellow eyes that show his descent to
the dark side much like anakin's eyes
turned yellow in revenge of the sith in
an episode o show called lafin ocho i
couldn't help but notice that the moment
of lopin ocho on the bridge in the
speeder reminded me a lot of the
beginning of solo a star wars story
where solo rides in the speeder with
someone who would betray him as well by
the end of the story and at the
beginning of the episode their father
uses the star wars swear term
that was popularized in the mandalorian
and finally in episode 9 akakiri we meet
tsubaki a jedi played by crazy rich
agents henry golding protecting the
young misa played by jamie chung who
played gogo tamago in big hero 6 after
misa's royal family is infiltrated by
the sith and senshu one of their guides
in this episode is voiced by star trek
legend george takei who returns to the
star wars universe after a brief cameo
in the clone wars tv show and it's
actually kind of really crazy how they
let this season end on such a dark tone
as tsubaki's story is a lot like anakin
skywalker's futile quest to defy the
fate of padme's death because he also
has these very disturbing visions like
tsubaki but inevitably like anakin his
attempts to fight the fate of the force
lead him to be the cause of the very
thing that he wanted to avoid leading
the evil sith masago voiced by lorraine
toussaint to lure him to the dark side
by actually providing him proof of the
dark side's ability to keep those he
loved from dying you know unlike
palpatine who didn't give anakin any
proof and didn't even help him out but
it is interesting to see that the dark
side can heal people much like the light
side can but that is it for this
breakdown of season 1 of star wars
visions what did you guys think of the
season let us know in the comment
section below my nerd babies thank you
guys so much for watching this video and
you can follow me at mastertainment if
you want to see me tweet some weird
but most importantly you can follow new
rockstars wherever we are on social
media but if you do on youtube make sure
to hit that notification bell so you get
notifications every time we upload
videos which we do every day because we
like to upload dope and make sure
to hit up new rockstarsmerch.com to get
some cool dope nerd shirts but anyways
i'll see you guys later goodbye
[Music]
you